ravi de vous retrouver sur public sénat
à l'occasion de la journée
internationale de la femme vous avez pu
suivre ce matin sur notre antenne
une table ronde consacrée au mariage
forcé cette première table ronde visait
à cerner la réalité cette pratique en
france cet après midi je vous propose de
suivre une seconde table ronde consacrée
à la prévention des mariages forcés
alors que le gouvernement a lancé en
2009 une campagne de prévention contre
ces pratiques tout de suite donc
direction la salle clémenceau bon après
midi à tous sur public sénat nous allons
compte commencer par madame catherine
moore bois madame vous avez la parole
matinée je voudrais dire que ma position
au sein de l'ensemble des communications
se situe à l'interface de l'action des
pouvoirs publics puisque j'ai été
déléguée régionale aux droits des femmes
durant 19 ans 17 ans en ile de france et
des associations mariage forcé mariage
contre un mariage arrangé
une femme peut être la cible d'individus
violent au sein de sa propre famille
pour des motifs divers comprenant
notamment le refus d'être entraînés dans
un mariage arrangé par ailleurs la
simple interprétation ou le seul soupçon
selon lequel son comportement aurait
déshonoré sa famille sont suffisants
pour enclencher un débordement de
représailles et le plus souvent deux
crimes dits d'honneur
ces derniers seront abordés cet
après-midi les violences que
représentent les mariages forcés
s'inscrivent dans le continuum des
violences faites aux femmes
continuum définis lors de la conférence
mondiale des femmes
à pékin en 1995 pour mémoire je rappelle
ce continuum de violence harcèlement
sexuel viols inceste et viols par
ascendant ou personne ayant autorité
violence dans le couple
mariages forcés violences exercées à
l'encontre de leur mère par leurs
enfants adolescents ou adultes
harcèlement sexuel des femmes au travail
mutilations sexuelles féminines
proxénétisme prostitution exploitation
sexuelle des enfants pornographie
violence liés aux intégrismes religieux
et aux pratiques coutumières font partie
de cet ensemble ces violences concerne
de très nombreuses femmes une
mobilisation s'impose pour prévenir ces
violences spécifiques
il est important de dire et de redire
que la loi française qualifie de viol
les rapports sexuels non consentis
les raps et rapports sexuels non
consentis sont liés inéluctablement au
mariage forcé ils sont commis par
violence contrainte menace ou surprise à
l'encontre de victimes souvent encore
mineure ils sont préméditées et mise en
oeuvre par la complicité d'adultes
parfois bien sûr on l'a vu les propres
parents des victimes le plus souvent
d'ailleurs ces actes constituent des
infractions criminelles aggravées les
violences ici évoqués ont un fondement
commun la domination sexiste domination
des hommes sur les femmes en 1985 lors
de la conférence de l'onu anaérobie les
états membres connaissait déjà la
caractéristique sexiste de la violence
masculine exercées à l'encontre des
femmes dans la même perspective la
déclaration de novembre 93 sur
l'élimination de la violence contre les
femmes
déclaration adoptée par l'assemblée
générale des nations unies précise la
violence faite aux femmes désigne tout
acte de violence fondée sur
l'appartenance au sexe féminin causant
ou susceptibles de causer aux femmes des
dommages ou des souffrances physiques
sexuelles ou psychologiques et
comprenant la menace de tels actes la
contrainte ou la privation arbitraire de
liberté que ce soit dans la vie publique
ou dans la vie privée il convient
évidemment de faire la différence entre
les déclarations officielles des
gouvernements est la réalité observable
dans les pays respectifs
notre pays a défini explicitement en 95
le cadre général de sa politique de
prise en charge de répression et
prévention de la violence masculine
exercée contre les femmes les
résistances furent nombreuses
l'une des plus fortes aujourd'hui encore
consiste à ne pas reconnaître l'origine
sexiste de la violence masculine
bien plus la pertinence de l'analyse
féministe est encore trop souvent
contesté voire nier
on s'en rend compte dans les actions de
formation proposés aux intervenants des
professions concernées
l'analyse individuelle intrapsychique
trop souvent présentée comme une
approche pertinente au détriment de ce
qui nous paraît fondamental à savoir
l'enracinement profond et structurel de
la domination des hommes sur les femmes
cette analyse individuelle dérange moins
ne serait ce parce qu'elles attribuent
l'effort les faits de violences à des
comportements singuliers liés à des
pathologies mentales ou sociale on en
conclut souvent que ces faits découle du
comportement de la victime
n'aurait-il pas été en quelque sorte
provoqué par cette victime celle-ci
deviendrait dès lors responsables de la
violence qu'on lui fait subir
l' approche féministe reconnue par
l'état de prise en compte de la violence
contre les femmes se situe dans une
perspective plus large historique et ou
sociologique
elles remettent en cause la répartition
des pouvoirs entre hommes et femmes
de ce fait la question de la violence
contre les femmes doit être traitée par
l'ensemble des axes des institutions et
des acteurs de la société l'action
contre la violence sexiste ne peut être
circonscrite aux missions de
professionnels de l'assistance aux
personnes
l'organisation générale de la société et
des rapports sociaux de sexe sont en
cause diverses circulaires et autres
plans triennaux encadrent l'action
publique
une feuille de route est rédigée pour
chaque ministère renforçant le
partenariat interministérielle en 89
alors que vous étiez en charge du droit
des femmes madame la ministre vous avez
organisé la première campagne publique
contre les violences conjugales dans ce
cadre vous avez instauré des instances
spécifiques qui doivent permettre aux
pouvoirs publics de prendre en charge ce
continuum des violences que j'ai évoqué
en introduction
c'est à cette époque en effet que
l'ensemble du pays au plan régional
s'est mis en place se sont mis en place
des commissions départementales d'action
contre les violences faites aux femmes
celles ci sont désormais d'ailleurs
intégré au comité départemental de
prévention de la délinquance
ces commissions je le rappelle sont
l'instrument de la mise en oeuvre de la
politique de l'état dans le domaine de
la lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes dans chaque département elles
réunissent des partenaires concernés
elle s'organise en sous commissions
thématiques de travail
chacune est placé sous l'autorité de
l'état
directement concerné par la proche
particulière police-justice
accompagnement social
piloté par la dass une commission
travaille sur la prévention des
mutilations sexuelles
et des mariages forcés en tout état de
cause concernant les mariages forcés
forcé il s'agit de mobiliser un large
partenariat il faut en effet accueillir
écouter les jeunes filles et les femmes
il s'agit d'assurer leur sécurité il
s'agit tout simplement d'appliquer la
loi en donnant accès aux droits accès
aux soins médicaux et à l'aide
psychologique
en bref répondre à leurs besoins
fondamentaux scolarisation formation
travail logement
ceci ne peut pas être le fait d'une
institution particulière ou d'un
organisme isolé le partenariat 5 pose
une réponse sociale doit être donnée aux
divers plans du droit de la loi de la
sanction de l'aide aux victimes et de la
condamnation des auteurs des prises en
charge et de la prévention
à cet effet les associations
spécialisées sont des partenaires
irremplaçable tant auprès des jeunes et
de leurs familles qu'auprès des
intervenants des différentes professions
concernées
la qualité de ces associations leur
compétence leur inlassable solidarité ne
doivent en rien dispenser les
institutions des charges qui leur
incombent leur détermination de ces
associations doivent entraîner celle des
pouvoirs publics
il s'agit de promouvoir et d'appliquer
des principes d'intervention clair
cinq d'entre eux me paraissent
absolument fondamentaux infondées
l'action sur la loi qui réprime les
actes de violence de utiliser des
dispositifs de protection des mineurs en
danger
3 exprimer une solidarité avec les
personnes confrontées à ces violences 4
attribué explicitement la responsabilité
de la violence aux auteurs des faits 5
renforcer les capacités des jeunes
filles à construire leur autonomie en
conclusion
les pouvoirs publics de notre pays ont
trop longtemps sous-estimé le poids des
mariages arrangés et ou forcés rendons
hommage à l'action des associations
spécialisées qui ont oeuvré dans ces
domaines
je ne peux que me souvenir de la
lourdeur du tabou et des réticences sont
rencontrés lorsqu'en 92 la délégation
régionale aux droits des femmes que je
dirigeais a mis en place en ile de
france avec les associations
spécialisées
la première campagne signée par l'état
pour lutter contre les mutilations
sexuelles féminines
cela ne nous concernait pas ben c'est
ton erreur gravissime
les chiffres issues d'enquêtés
scientifiques prouvent est le contraire
de même depuis plusieurs années la prise
en charge des mariages forcés devient
heureusement une réalité de façon
analogue
s'agissant des crimes dits d'honneur
de quoi parle-t-on au juste il ne
concerne pas seulement les autres pays
il est grand temps de regarder de près
ce dont il s'agit on ne peut plus fuir
la réalité il est nécessaire que le
crime dit d'honneur qui sera approfondie
cet après midi donc disais-je que ce
crime dit d'honneur soit à l'avenir
aborder ouvertement aux salles de nos
instances de concertation ne craignons
pas d'aborder ce problème très
concrètement restreint cette notion de
crime dit d'honneur à l'assassinât d'une
femme sur ordre de sa famille par l'un
de ses proches ne suffit pas nos voisins
hollandais vont plus loin ils associent
de nombreuses infractions délictuels ou
criminels à la notion d'honneur
nous sommes encore au début d'une
réflexion qu'il est indispensable
d'approfondir avant de terminer mon
intervention je voudrais insister sur le
fait
il est nécessaire que les pouvoirs
publics se donne les moyens dans ce
domaine de la lutte contre les violences
faites aux femmes
comme dans tous les autres domaines qui
contribuent à l'égalité entre les femmes
et les et les hommes de promouvoir une
politique globale cohérente et
coordonnée que soit donnée à ceux qui
sont chargés de la mettre en oeuvre plus
au plus près des réalités du terrain je
pense aux délégation régionale aux
droits des femmes à l'échelon des
régions et des départements
une feuille de route claire avec une
visibilité de moyen avéré en personnel
et en budget car il semble bien que la
réforme de l'administration engagé par
la rgpp révision générale des politiques
publiques semblent avoir fragilisé
l'administration en charge des droits
des femmes et de l'égalité dans tant du
point de vue de sa gouvernance que de
ses moyens actuels et à venir
cette journée arrive à point d'heure à
point nommé merci à vous madame michèle
andré un grand merci
madame martin moore bois merci soyez
sûrs que ce message à madame andrée sera
donnée et elle revient tout à l'heure
mais je lui dirai encore personnellement
je suis tout à fait d'accord avec vous
que l'ensemble des institutions doivent
traiter des violences envers les femmes
l'ensemble des institutions vous avez
parfaitement raison et j'ai été très
touchée aussi que vous soulignez que
notre présidente a été a fait la
première campagne publique
quant aux violences faites aux femmes
certainement ça va beaucoup la touche et
je vous en remercie madame mais je suis
sûr qu'à la fin de notre colloque vous
aurez des questions maintenant je donne
la parole à madame latifa drif membres
de l'association départementale du
planning familial de montpellier vous
avez la parole madame n est pas là
vous préférez aller là le mieux oui puis
la collecte a essayé de me passer
je pense que ça leur met vous
approcherez bien s'il vous plaît pour
qu'on puisse je mange les micros comme
dit mon ami justin donc bonjour moi je
travaille donc au planning familial à
montpellier et je vous propose de
balayer les grandes lignes de notre
démarche pour prévenir les mariages
forcés
il s'agit d'un réseau de professionnels
qui a été initiée en 2000 suite à une
situation que nous avions appelée à
l'époque une épidémie de mariage forcé
il s'agissait de plusieurs jeunes filles
qui étaient venus demander de l'aide au
planning familial pour échapper à un
mariage et nous n'avions d'autre
solution que leur proposer une écoute
nous avons donc décidé d'interpeller
d'interpeller les partenaires donc
associations et institutions pour leur
partage et donc le notre questionnement
et parler de ce phénomène
cette première rencontre tous les
professionnels ont reconnu que la
problématique existe et que la situation
était loin d'être exceptionnel donc est
né ce groupe intitulé réseau jeune fille
confrontée aux violences et aux ruptures
familiales donc très vite on a été
confronté aux garçons à la la situation
des garçons et pour travailler ensemble
donc puisque la lors de la première
rencontre il y avait une forte demande
de réflexion collective et il fallait
donc mettre en place un certain nombre
d'outils et notamment la coordination et
l'animation du groupe de travail la
communication donc à l'interné et à
l'externe la formation des membres du du
réseau par des intervenants extérieurs
et bien sûr le dernier volet qui
j'espère va être en cours qui est
l'évaluation
alors pour construire ce travail
ensemble et développer cette culture
commune parler de la même chose
donc notre approche se décline en trois
volets la première c'est l'animation et
le développement du réseau
alors la seconde c'est la prévention
c'est objet principal j'ai envie de dire
l'objectif principal le même dieu du
réseau et le troisième volet c'est
l'accompagnement et la prise en charge
pour ce qui est de l'animation et du
développement du réseau
parler de la même chose s'est élaboré
des outils qui permettent dans un
premier temps de quantifier de
quantifier l situations rencontrées donc
nous avons élaboré une grille d'accueil
une fiche dans la calant dans laquelle
on recueille toutes les informations et
même les solutions proposées dans le
cadre de réunions qui sont généralement
mensuel et au cours desquels il ya
toujours des études de situation nous
avons aussi réalisé à un guide un
annuaire parce que nous sommes rendu
compte que les partenaires se
connaissaient mais en fait ne connaissez
pas tout à fait l'émission pour
l'émission des ddd aussi bien des
institutions et des associations qui
étaient impliqués dans le réseau et en
enfin nous avons organisé des séminaires
et des journées de sensibilisation pour
faire connaître d'une part à la
problématique et élargir à d'autres
professionnels
nous avons en 2004 ou 2005 écrit une
charte donc un document qui fait
référence à notre cadre de travail en
termes de méthodologie et en termes
d'éthique alors toujours dans le cadre
de l'animation et dans le développement
et le développement du du réseau nous
avons a fait appel à une étudiante pour
analyser un peu les récits de vie ouais
alors qu'il s'agit d'un dindane et moi
qui a été fait à l'université de
montpellier à partir des histoires de
vie que nous avions recueilli à 7 à
cette époque là pour avoir une
définition parler de la même chose et
donc cette définition s'inscrit
complètement dans l'intervention très
claire de madame hors bois ensuite il ya
eu la question des familles donc qui est
une question qui était récurrente nous
travaillons avec des des personnes
concernées nous étions des
professionnels et en même temps il y
avait les familles auteurs les familles
marieuse si je peux appeler que ça comme
ça et nous avons demandé à la même
étudiante de réfléchir à la prévention
donc des mariages forcés et en même
temps et en même temps à la à la
prévention de la rupture familiale donc
ce travail à
à a donné trois pistes donc à toi tous
trois pré pistes de travail la première
c'est l'élaboration de documents
d'information la seconde demande
d'arrêter c'est pas grave du tout hein
c'est pas grave la seconde est de former
les professionnels au sens large
donc pour nous les professionnels c'est
travailleurs sociaux l'éducation
nationale les juristes des magistrats
etc et enfin la troisième piste était
réfléchir à une forme de rencontres avec
les familles donc ça c'est une question
qui reste très très compliqué qu'on n'a
pas réussi à faire ensuite pour ce qui
est de la prévention donc nous avons mis
en place des journées de sensibilisation
est outré des professionnels des
journées aussi de formation des journées
de sensibilisation dans les
établissements scolaires nous avons
aussi réalisé une carte
donc ça c'est la première vous pouvez y
aller merci donc une première carte qui
a été fait avec le soutien d'une
étudiante en communication à
l'université paul valéry et enfin nous
avons mis en ligne un site internet un
site internet
donc 3 w mariage forcé point fr qui a
été fait avec le soutien des jeunes
concernés ou non et des établissements
scolaires
pour ce qui est de l'accompagnement et
la prise en charge je vais vous demander
de passer toute la diapo comme ça pour
ce qui est de l'accompagnement et de la
prise en charge
donc là la difficulté majeure qui a été
pointée aider la mise en place du réseau
et la question de l'hébergement
fortement souligné tout à l'heure
notamment par mon ami justin du gams
donc la difficulté est d'avoir des
hébergements et en particulier des
errements des hébergements d'urgence
il existe comme vous le savez les
hébergements en centre d'hébergement et
réinsertion sociale des bons d'hôtel des
foyers de jeunes travailleurs mais qui
ce sont des des solutions qui ne sont
pas complètement adaptée aux jeunes qui
généralement n'ont pas d'autres
problématiques que là le projet de
mariage auquel elles sont il son contrat
alors nous avons monté un dispositif
trémie d'accueil et en 2003 il ya eu un
appel d'offres par la fnar ce pour une
action innovante et nous avons donc a
répondu à l'appel à un projet qui a été
accepté et nous avons dégagé du réseau
donc des professionnels institutions et
associations un comité de pilotage et un
comité technique qui a permis qui a
permis de travailler les documents de
travail le protocole pour construire le
dispositif famille d'accueil recruter
les familles d'accueil et permettre donc
l'accueil et l'accompagnement des jeunes
victimes ou le nez ses deux mariages
forcés
alors alors évidemment l'hébergement en
famille d'accueil est une solution
alternative est ce à ce qui existe elle
permet de sécuriser la personne et
d'agir sur l'estimé de soi
je signale que ce dispositif
voilà donc il ya trois objectifs donc la
mise en sécurité bien sûr favoriser
l'accompagnement social qu'est ce qui a
été signalé tout à l'heure pendant la
durée de l'accueil et en même temps
la travail et l'autonomie de la personne
les i alors concrètement comment ça
marche
je vous propose de passer toute la diapo
de manière à ce que ce soit peut-être un
petit peu plus explicite
donc concrètement le planning pilote le
groupe de travail est en lien avec les
professionnels s'occupent de la
communication et depuis 2007 pour
pérenniser le dispositif famille
d'accueil qui venait d'être évalué
d'ailleurs de manière très positive
un membre du réseau qui est une maison
d'enfants qui s'appelle la dre
languedocien a repris le flambeau pour
coordonner le dispositif famille
d'accueil et coordonnée l'accompagnement
donc vous voyez qu'il ya une espèce de
deux cercles de réseaux comme son nom
l'indiqué qui fait que donc les
professionnels travaillent ensemble
autour d'un objet commun qui est la
personne victimes menacées de mariage
forcé vous passez la suivante merci
alors pour la prise en charge
vous voyez que c'est l'intervention
pluridisciplinaire qui avait qui a été
fortement soulignée par madame marois
donc la personne qui arrive auprès d'une
structure aux membres du réseau ou non -
donc l'accompagnement dans le dans le
projet l'accompagnement juridique et
l'information juridique qui est
important parce que le constat est que
beaucoup de professionnels et beaucoup
d'eau de jeunes ne connaissent pas les
droits
éventuellement des aides financières
proposition d'un accompagnement
psychologique puisque dans le réseau il
ya des structures qui avec des
psychologues
et là bien sûr les coudes et le soutien
qui nous semble le pilier fondamental
pour l'accompagnement des jeunes dans
cette situation
la régularisation des papiers
administrative lorsque les jeunes
viennent de loin donc la sécurité
sociale
la domiciliation et c'est alors quelques
chiffres depuis qu'on a la grille donc
depuis 2001 nous avons reçu 550
situation dont une dizaine de garçons
repéré essentiellement par le parc des
partenaires donc des membres du réseau
qui sont l'amicale du nid qui s'occupe
de personnes en situation de
prostitution et angèle l'association
angers l'association des nouveaux gay et
lesbian en 2009 nous avons eu 45
situation dont 10 reçu par mail
deux situations parmi les 45 concerne
des femmes sans papiers dont une qui a
fui l'algérie pourrait donc échapper à
un mariage forcé une seconde qui
elle-même a été victime de mariage forcé
en algérie mais qui a fui parce que sa
fille était devait être mariées de force
par au cours de la séparation avec son
conjoint enfin ou en 2009 nous avons
recueilli les témoignages s'avéreront
nous on avance en argent et nous avons
noté tous les témoignages aussi bien
auprès des professionnels qu'aux prix
des jeunes que nous rencontrons dans le
cadre des interventions et
et de là des questions de prévention du
planning familial
en 2010 neuf situation donc depuis
janvier dont trois concernent des
mineurs donc on voit bien que la
question de la loi même si 6 à 18 ans
les parents peuvent la contourner ou
suivante merci alors une démarche qui
est partagé et des initiatives ont été
lancées dans d'autres départements en
particulier par les associations
départementales du planning familial je
cite notamment grenoble lézignan les
cordes year blois et récemment montauban
par ailleurs le planning familial
confédéral a obtenu des financements
récemment pour développer une action
nationale de prévention qui va se
décliner en régions ou par des colloques
et de la formation des professionnels et
aussi par une campagne de prévention la
dernière je suis allé très vite
alors la conclusion c'est que pour nous
les mariages forcés est une
problématique complexe qui fait
intervenir obligatoirement d un chant
pluridisciplinaire et qui permet d'être
un levier pour prendre en charge et
prévenir aussi bien les les personnes
qui sont concernées mais aussi les
professionnels qui sont interpellés par
cette question
alors voilà donc les derniers outils
c'est une affiche donc nous avons voulu
rester un petit peu dans la continuité
et l'esprit du site internet
et puis à droite vous avez une petite
plaquette d'information format 4 bars
carte bancaire donc ça aussi ça a été
une idée faut donc venant des jeunes qui
pour eux avaient besoin d'avoir une
carte facilement que utilisable et
qu'ils pouvaient avoir
enfin cacher et pouvoir distribuer dans
leur entourage
si vous pouvez passer juste
l'introduction merci du donc du site
c'est donc c'est un site qu'on a lancé
en 2000 fans 2000 le vide
fin 2008 et auquel ont contribué trois
lycées et beaucoup de jeunes qui
viennent en consultation au planning
familial
donc il rassemble une foire aux
questions qui a été complètement puiser
dans dans les situations et les récits
de vie une page sur les aspects
juridiques des témoignages donc aux jo
et de jeunes qui est qui et que nous
avons rencontrés et puis aussi des
adresses avec des partenaires en france
donc je cite notamment donc le gams voix
de femmes d'associations et l'ailé
aujourd'hui la fondation surgir qui est
présente dans la salle et d'autres
associations qui sont dans par exemple
en allemagne comme papa papa tia et les
terres des femmes là l'unité des
mariages forcés en grande bretagne donc
excusez moi je suis allé très vite pour
balayer un petit peu là la charpente de
de notre démarche qui a pour premier
objectif donc la prévention des mariages
forcés
merci madame drif s'était également très
intéressant vous nous avez dit que vous
aviez reçu cinq ans 550 situation dont
dix garçons vous ne nous avons pas parlé
des problèmes des garçons peut-être
pourriez-vous de faire tout à l'heure
lorsque il y aura des questions et puis
pourriez vous répétez l'adresse du site
vous avez été si vite l'a pas prise www
bon alors il était inscrit paraît-il
comme je ne vois pas dans mon dos j'ai
pu voir très bien on pourra la voir à ce
point
aso points adami tu m'as dit que c'était
sa mariage mariage 3-2
www.mariasharapova.com c'est très simple
merci madame ma chance et sans accent au
mieux merci madame
alors je vais donner la parole
maintenant à madame christine jamal qui
est à côté de moi
juriste et directrice de l'association
voix de femmes protection des victimes
droit commun et mesures spécifiques vous
avez la parole madame merci je remercie
sénan d'accueillir l'association voix de
femme j'étais très touchée en écoutant
karima tout à l'heure parce que nadia
qui a fondé voix de femme lorsqu'elle
avait 17 ans s'était confié à son
l'assistante sociale scolaire qu'il
avait cru au sujet des menaces qu'elle
subissait à la maison et malheureusement
juge pour enfants près de qu'elle avait
demandé une protection de ma vie dit
c'est ta culture tu dois t'y soumettre
résultat des courses nadia s'est
retrouvée séquestrée pendant six années
en algérie et elle a eu la chance de
revenir parce que c'est pas le cas de
toutes les jeunes filles qu'on suit
puisque nous ne voyons que la partie
visible de l'iceberg
celle qui se révoltent celles qui
reviennent
et voilà donc donc le mariage forcé on
l'a on a répété c'est une violence faite
aux femmes qui est intrinsèquement liée
à la domination masculine
même les garçons français de souche
qu'on reçoit qui qui vont épouser de
force des jeunes filles bien azattyk
parce que soi disant bien soumise
parce que ces garçons là les parents
pensent que comme ils sont ce sont des
garçons on a découvert un réseau de 2
comme ça de mariages forcés de garçons
toxicomanes qui a été mariée à les
jeunes filles asiatiques parce que ça
les calme et de la toxicomanie
certains garçons étaient aussi
homosexuel et les parents pensaient que
ça allait rendre hétérosexuels de les
marier de force avec des femmes c'est
bien connu
donc voilà c'est vraiment on est lié
dans la question de la domination
masculine et d'une sexualité genre est
aussi et puis évidemment la question de
l'égalité et des droits des femmes
donc dans ce contexte comment est ce que
on peut s'assurer que les personnes qui
seront exposés à un mariage forcé seront
considérés comme des femmes victimes de
violence à part entière et qui auront
besoin et droit à une protection et non
pas comme des jeunes filles en proie à
un problème d'intégration au
d'ambivalence identitaire comme je
l'entends encore hélas trop souvent
puisque elle est née six l'ethnicisation
l'après la préservation de la culture ou
du lien sacré de la famille
malheureusement sont encore des motifs
ou même des alibis et d'autant d'autant
plus d'obstacle donc à dans un contexte
français ou le chemin vers
l'émancipation n'est pas n'est pas chose
aisée puisque il est mise à mal par
encore trop souvent par les réticences
de certains professionnels à appliquer
ou s'autoriser à appliquer la loi
républicaine républicaine tandis que
d'autres vont construire des outils de
protection spécifique innovant donc le
réseau de montpellier en était un
exemple tandis que le conseil de
l'europe a préconisé dans sa dernière
résolution donc de d'avril 2009 de la
commission égalité des chances entre les
femmes et les hommes de construire des
outils spécifiques pour corriger les
inégalités dont sont victimes certaines
femmes en pro mariage forcé aux crimes
d'honneur notamment
alors j'espère que que ces perspectives
qui s'ouvrent aujourd'hui grâce aux
recommandations européennes et aussi aux
récentes évolutions législatives qui ont
été votées par notre assemblée nationale
le 25 février
dernier j'espère que ces perspectives
vont s'appliquer en termes de protection
dont je vais d'abord vous expliquer un
petit peu quelle est la législation de
droit commun je vais pas rentrer dans
les détails si ce n'est que bon les
personnes qui sont en proie à un mariage
forcé relève de la protection de
l'enfance en danger et de la lutte
contre les violences faites aux femmes
on l'a on a suffisamment répété depuis
le 4 avril 2006 le viol conjugal a été
légalement donc reconnu les conditions
d'un mariage non consenti ont été
assouplies et l'âge légal du mariage a
été levée à 18 ans on était quand même
en retard sur la droiture son droit
marocain je tire alsw email mais encore
faut-il que cet arsenal législatif soit
appliquée sur le terrain et nous avons
pu constater à voix de femme que les
réticences ne venait pas toujours des
corps de métiers que l'on imaginait
puisque je suis ravi de constater au
jour le jour que les policiers et les
gendarmes applique de plus en plus les
lois contre les retraites aux femmes et
encourage les jeunes femmes à porter
plainte pour viol aggravé si elles sont
mineures ou si le jeune a été commis
dans le cadre conjugal
al'inverse certains cordes sainte un
corps de métier comme notamment les
éducateurs sont ne sont pas très claires
sur le caractère contraint du mariage
forcé je peux vous donner un exemple on
a reçu une jeune femme d'origine
pakistanaise qui qui était menacé leurs
mariages forcés elles avaient demandé un
soutien donc auprès d'un éducateur dans
un tribunal à qui a été confiée et puis
quelques jours plus tard sa mère
qui ne voulait pas entendre le refus de
sa fille
son refus du mariage forcé avait tenté
de s'immoler donc de stimuler devant
elle vous imaginer la violence du de
l'acte je trouve même pas les mots
et du coup la jeune fille se sentant
coupable eh bien allez retournez entrée
au tribunal en disant que tout s'est
arrangé ensuite l'été après l'été
approchait les mariages forcés aussi la
jeune fille entre temps était devenu
majeur ce qui était bien sauf que
lorsqu'elle est venue demander une
protection jeunes majeurs auprès du
tribunal en expliquant un petit peu
qu'elle a vécu elle voulait vraiment
partir que maintenant ils étaient prêtes
on lui a refusé
et parce que c'est vrai que
malheureusement sur encore beaucoup de
départements en france la protection
jeunes majeurs jeune majeur alors que
légalement rien n'oblige à ce qu'un
suivi pendant la minorité est accordée
que si la jeune fille avait déjà était
protégé quand elle était mineure et donc
quand je lui ai dit quand j'ai eu son
éducateur au téléphone il m'a répondu
vous savez elle aurait pas dû changer
d'avis et puis ces problèmes de choc des
cultures de choc décisif d'asson c'est
quand même complexe donc si tu le disais
tout à l'heure
madame andrée mallah michel andré m'a
fait boucle enfin fait vraiment un
véritable écho dans ce conte ce qu'on
vit au quotidien sur le terrain et
combien d'assistantes sociales aussi
scolaires ne sont pas toujours soutenu
par soutenus par leur propre hiérarchie
ou même par le juge lorsqu'elle demande
un placement d'une mineure sans
rencontrer au préalable la famille et ça
c'est encore possible un dans dans le
lin dans les textes parce que elles
savent que si jamais les parents sont
informés ils vont renvoyer encore plus
vite les petites au pays
ça c'est ces gens n'aient eu trois
situations là depuis le mois de janvier
d'assistantes sociales complètement
désemparés parce que soient elles se
sont fait avoir ou soit elle certes il y
en a une qui a convoqué la famille en se
disant bon je vais quand même voir un
petit peu ce qui se passe
la famille a expliqué que bon vous savez
si elles avaient tabassé leur fille
parce qu'elle avait fumé dans la rue
c'était c'était juste un acte isolé un
tabassage comme ça un peu ponctuels
parce que c'est vrai que je suis mais
c'est très grave et résultat des courses
à la jeune fille qui est quand même une
collégienne de 15 ans était renvoyé en
tunisie
donc voilà alors on a un autre problème
les
et à ce que j'appelle la
territorialisation de la prise en charge
qui fait que lorsqu'on est en danger le
mariage forcé notre situation doit être
évaluée par une assistante sociale de la
ville où habitent nos parents en général
en plus quand on est mineur on habite
encore chez ses parents
et alors c'est ça pose un problème mais
heureusement je vais passer maintenant
la question des bonnes pratiques
innovantes qui ont été mises en oeuvre
pour soi mieux appliquer le droit commun
ou même carrément créer des dispositifs
spécifiques à ce jour sur le territoire
français il ya il n'existe qu'un seul
conseil général en l'occurrence celui
celui de la seine saint denis qui a mis
en place un protocole départemental de
lutte contre le mariage forcé emmanuelle
piet tous les aspics à ce matin et qui
est vraiment unique en france parce
qu'il permet une prise en charge de la
victime par un travailleur social du
lieu où elle a trouvé refuge
donc ça peut être chez une copine ou une
tante qui est contre marat sûr c'est
donc c'est ce n'est pas rien ce set ce
contournement ce même pas un
contournement la loi c'est une
adaptation d'un de ce qui relève du
réglementaire ce n'est pas rien quand on
sait que lorsque l'évaluation est faite
par les travailleurs sociaux du secteur
où habitent les parents certains
éducateurs se sentent un petit peu dans
la toute puissance et font alliance avec
la famille et du coup bas mais c'est pas
dans l'intérêt de la jeune fille et ce
qui est important aussi c'est que dans
le cadre de ce protocole les
associations agissent en subsidiarité ça
veut dire qu'en aucun cas elle ne se
substitue au droit commun ça c'est
vraiment important de le rappeler du
coup sa ré inscrire les professionnels
dans leur mission je dirais complètement
normal quand on est en danger de
mariages forcés on est une annonce enfin
une mineure en danger ou une femme en
danger point barre mais ce n'est pas
autre chose et ça nous permet nous aussi
des associations d'être mobilisés
justement alors c'est un gâteau alors
c'est un gain de temps aussi pour les
pour les victimes de ce qu'elles sont
obligées de raconter leur histoire
trente six mille fois en tout cas en
seine saint denis quand on est confronté
un mariage forcé ça parle au travers
sociaux actions se confie et puis
singles parce qu'ils sont formés et
c'est un gain de temps aussi pour les
pour nous parce que on
croyez moi qu'on a d'autres choses à
faire malheureusement on a on doit agir
sur des mesures de protection très
spécifique pour lesquelles on nous
contactons dernier recours et là j'ai du
coup je vais aborder la question de
l'aide des difficultés des personnes que
nous recevons qui sont en lien direct
avec un risque de renvois forcés au pays
vous savez les jeunes filles sont
fréquemment marié aux pays d'origine des
parents
certaines subissent avant le mariage
forcé des mesures de redressement qui
vont de l'avortement franc de
l'avortement forcé si elles ont eu un
enfant hors mariage à plusieurs mois de
séquestration et puis si elles
reviennent pas tous pas vraiment dans le
droit chemin en gros si elle ne se
soumettent pas eh ben on les marie de
force donc c'est un viol
chantal brunel a acquis et député a bien
rappelé à l'assemblée nationale le 25
février dernier que c'était un viol
officialisé et malheureusement ça peut
aller aussi jusqu'au crime d'honneur
alors le conseil de l'europe a vraiment
invité dans sa résolution du 28 avril
2009 les états membres à créer des
dispositifs spécifiques en lien avec ces
violences au pays d'origine et notamment
de nous appuyer sur le modèle anglais
qui a créé donc une un dispositif qui
s'appelle fmi ça veut dire forces
marines unit donc il assure notamment en
termes de protection spécifique le
changement d'identité et le rapatriement
et nous avons tout à gagner à suivre la
grande bretagne
et croyez-moi le pragmatisme anglais et
l'onatra clichés parce que leur
gouvernement n'a pas attendu d'avoir des
statistiques pour pour agir alors je dis
pas qu'il faut pas statistiques en
france puisqu on fonctionne peut-être
différemment mais je pense qu'on peut
agir sans les avoir tout de suite
et puis comme l'avait aussi si justement
rappelé le directeur consulaire de la
force marois unit que j'ai rencontré un
colloque au canada un colloque
international sur le mariage forcé ont
ils ont arrêté de réfléchir pendant dix
ans sur est ce que c'est forcé est-ce
que ça arrange et finalement ils se sont
dit on va mettre en place ce dispositif
alors et croyez moi il est très efficace
nous il nous a servis en juin dernier
pour localiser une jeune fille française
d'origine sri lankaise qui était c'est
qu'il serait à londres pour un petit
stage de redressement
chez une tante
avant d'être renvoyé au canada où elle
devait épouser son cousin germain
alors est-ce qu'on peut envisager une
une fmi anglaise à la française pour
l'instant voix de femmes on a réalisé à
la demande du ministère de l'immigration
donc fait une étude de faisabilité d'un
projet qui s'appelle cellule à l'herbe
veille et d'intervention donc qui se
proposerait de résoudre trois
difficultés majeures d'abord signaler
les retraits de l'école où les
déscolarisation jeune femme qu'ils sont
mais qui sont à l'école parce que c'est
quand même majoritairement ce moment de
la scolarisation qu'on les marais de
force mettre en oeuvre les rapatriements
évidemment en partenariat avec je le
vire au de la protection des mineurs et
de la famille qui représentait
aujourd'hui je suis ravi de vous revoir
madame serre on s'est plus de plus plus
plus souvent au téléphone que dans les
colloques et puis aussi le cas échéant
de va j'ai déjà dit les interdictions de
sortie territoire je crois que j'ai déjà
dit je suis plus mais maintenant je vois
là où je termine d'accord alors ce que
je voulais dire c'est que je vais être
que je vais conclure sur des
préconisations législatives puisque au
regard des avancées qui ont été votées
par l'assemblée nationale le 25 février
dernier puisque on a quand même obtenu
le rapatriement des françaises et des
résident des jeunes femmes résidant
habituellement en france
enfin en espérant que celle de votre
part contre cet amendement
nous avons également obtenu
l'interdiction de sortie du territoire
pour les mineurs et les majeurs ce qui
n'était pas ce qui était pas gagné d
avance et je voudrais rappeler que
protégé de victimes puisque c'était
sujet de mon intervention c'est aussi
lui permettre d'exercer le droit de
porter plainte
le problème c'est que on a alors
l'assemblée nationale a voté des
circonstance aggravante en cas de
contraintes matrimoniale pour les
infractions suivantes violence actes de
tortures de barbarie et de meurtre c'est
un progrès indéniable mais il nous
paraît insuffisant pourquoi puisqu'il
est regrettable qu'une infraction
d'enlèvement de séquestration de viol et
d'assassinât n'était pas être n'ait pas
été prise en compte
il est sale hebdo et c'est d'autant plus
regrettable que comme vous le savez ou
pas je ne sais pas l'arctique
le centre et sept du nouveau code de
procédure pénale pour que la loi pénale
soit applicable
il ya trois conditions pour que qui
doivent être remplies enfin une une
parmi ces trois conditions soient
l'auteur et français de l'infraction
soit la victime est française ou soit
l'infraction a été commise sur le
territoire français sauf que il ya
beaucoup de jeunes filles et moi en ce
moment je suis un nombre important de
petits couples soit indiens pakistanais
ou albanais qui sont en proie à des
crimes d'honneur y compris les garçons
et leur famille leur dit clairement mais
nous on va te tuer au pays d'origine
parce que ce sont des populations qui
sont pas encore française donc la fille
on va là dessus au pays d'origine
et c'est vrai que l'on pourra pas
sanctionner les parents c'est la raison
pour lesquelles j'espère que ces
amendements seront votés aussi pour
élargir cette dérogation législatives
comme on l'a fait pour l'excision qu'on
le fasse aussi pour je répète les
infractions d'enlèvement de
séquestration de viol maréchaussée stand
hall et d'assassinats parce que kim
manners d'un assassinat et rien d'autre
merci beaucoup madame je regrette de me
bousculer un petit peu mais comme il ya
d'autres internautes
nous voudrions nous allons passer
maintenant à l'action des pouvoirs
publics et madame clémentine blanc
ministère de la justice magistrate
adjointe au chef du bureau des droits
des personnes et de la famille direction
des affaires civiles et du sceau madame
clémentine blanche vous donne la parole
je vous remercie madame là je voudrais
remercier madame andrée monsieur vance
vous madame et puis me tous les toutes
les personnes de la de la délégation aux
droits des femmes qui sont présentes
aujourd'hui de m'avoir donné cette
opportunité de devenir parce que j'ai
été très touchée je dois dire assez
bouleversé par par les témoignages des
deux victimes
fatou et est carrément ce qu'elle savait
eu le courage de d'abord pour elle même
à titre personnel de se sortir de cette
situation et de se reconstruire
ensuite d'agir pour les autres en
écrivant un ouvrage à destination du
grand public en fait pour faire mieux
connaître ces situations et puis ensuite
le courage supplémentaire de fer par an
publiques dans un face à face ce qui je
pense est encore plus difficile de leur
vécu et de ce que ça peut engendrer même
des années après donc voilà j'ai été
très très touché de peu de pouvoir
entendre cela alors ces deux témoignages
et puis d'autres celui du docteur pied
ce matin faisant état de de la situation
de cette jeune de 15 ans qu'il avait pu
recevoir le le punch de madame jamana
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que ça donne une
vision un peu de la réalité des mariages
forcés encore aujourd'hui en france et
j'aimerais d'abord insisté sur le sur le
terme du encore parce que effectivement
on a tendance à considérer que les
mariages forcés on les voit plutôt sous
le sous le prisme en fait de quelque
chose qui nous seraient importés de
cultures étrangères comme madame andrée
a pu dire dans son allocution
d'ouverture
toutefois je pense qu'il faut pas
oublier ce important elle a évoqué
molière et ses mariages arrangés de
cette époque là mais c'est quelque chose
qui a perduré même au delà de l'époque
de molière
les unions princières que ce soit en
france ou dans toute l'europe faut pas
l'oublier c'était des mariages arrangés
si vous voulez certains d'entre vous ont
vu ou revu récemment le film de sofia
coppola
vous aurez peut-être le souvenir de des
premières images on voit une marie
antoinette ou junk 14 15 ans je me
souviens plus exactement arrivé être pas
franchement ravi de ce qui l'attend
alors que par rapport à ce que nous ont
des cris d'horreur les deux les deux
victimes
ça pouvait paraître une situation plus
plus confortable donc on voit bien que
c'est quelque chose qui remontent à une
période très ancienne qui étaient en
cours et en pratique en france a
continué dans un sous un mode un peu
différent mais manque au cours du 19e
siècle dans certaines catégories
sociales faut pas oublier que les
mariages étaient souvent arranger alors
arranger ça veut pas forcément dire
qu'ils s'étaient forcé vous pouvez avoir
des découpes des monts
conjoints ou l'un d'entre eux qui sait
que le mariage a été programmée ou
prévus ou conduit à présenter un
conjoint et qui sont sans contente c'est
son choix à la limite n'a pas à revenir
dessus mais faut quand même pas oublier
que c'est quelque chose qui a existé il
ya pas si longtemps que ça et que par
conséquent lorsqu'on parle de ces
cultures lâche dans lesquels il y a
encore ceux là qui se pratique chez elle
il faut pas oublier que nous on l'a
pratiqué pendant longtemps et que donc
il faut porter un regard j'ai envie de
dire avec ce recul 1 et cette mise en
cause d'abord de notre propre pratique
de notre propre regard à la liberté
notamment la liberté des femmes
alors ceci étant dit je vous avais eu
donc le point de vue social le point de
vue des victimes le point de vue de la
prise en charge le point de vue de
l'intervention des associations et la
difficulté de leur leur intervention
parce qu'il faut qu'elle arrive à mettre
en place des dispositifs qui soit
adaptée à chaque situation s'est
compliquée
c'est compliqué de trouver une solution
à la fois sur le plan d'hébergement sur
le plan d'urgence trouver une solution
dans l'urgence est une chose trouver une
solution dans le long terme c'est encore
différent et donc c'est un travail de
longue haleine
alors les pouvoirs publics ils ont tenté
d'accompagner ce mouvement sans doute
avec beaucoup de retard on peut espérer
qu'il ya une prise de conscience qui va
maintenant aller en s'accélérant
alors pour bien poser le débat en
revenir à quelque chose d'assez simple
et donc et c'est comprendre qu'est-ce
que c'est juridiquement un mariage forcé
un mariage des dix force et lorsqu'il
est conclue sans le consentement du ou
des époux concernés parce qu'après tout
on peut tout à fait concevoir une
situation dans laquelle les deux
seraient opposés ou lorsque son
consentement est contraint et cette
règle là elle est posée dans le code
civil depuis très longtemps
elle existait maintenant droit français
même avant le code civil puisque en
réalité elles datent de 1803 donc si on
a éprouvé le besoin de le rappeler à la
cette époque il y avait déjà une prise
de conscience d'une difficulté et donc
la règle est la suivante actuellement
dans le code civil à l'article 146 il
n'y a pas de mariage lorsqu'il ya point
de consentement alors le mariage forcé y
faut le distinguer en partie du mariage
arrangé jeu on l'a vu tout à l'heure
mais aussi
du marais et surtout du mariage de
complaisance ou mariage dit parfois
simuler ou encore mariages blancs dans
le langage courant
et puis aussi de cette nouvelle
catégorie découverte un peu récemment
donc celle du mariage degree pourquoi il
se distingue du mariage de complaisance
dans le mariage de complaisance vous
avez un consentement un consentement des
deux simplement vous avez un
consentement sur quelque chose sur un
objectif qui était étranger à l'objectif
aux intention matrimoniale
c'est à dire que dans le cas d'un
mariage blanc de complaisance ou simuler
les personnes sont d'accord pour se
marier mais non pas pour quelque chose
qui est conforme à l'objectif de l'union
matrimoniale mais qu'il n'ya rien à voir
le cas auquel on pense que plus souvent
bien sûr c'est l'idée de pouvoir pour
l'un d'entre eux obtenir des papiers
d'identité en france - permis de séjour
etc
mais vous n'avez pas que cette situation
là faut pas l'oublier vous pouvez aussi
imaginer des situations de mariages de
complaisance par exemple pour faciliter
une adoption l'heure actuelle vous avez
des conditions strictes pour pouvoir
adopter dans un certain nombre de cas
bien que l'adoption par un célibataire
soit possible à l'est plus difficile et
vous pouvez tout à fait avoir un mariage
simulé de ce type donc il faut pas
oublier le mariage forcé ça n'a rien à
voir ou pas grand chose à voir avec le
mariage de complaisance et donc le
constant le mariage forcé vous avez une
contrainte du consentement ou une
absence totale là le consentement contre
1st vice du consentement ce n'est pas la
seule façon de le vicié mais c'est la
façon la plus la plus évidente alors les
ce qu'il faut bien voir c'est que les
pouvoirs publics leur action dans le
cadre de la de la lutte ou la prévention
des mariages forcés
elle est compliquée par le fait qu' elle
doit se situer à établir un juste
équilibre entre cette lutte là qui est
nécessaire qui est indispensable qui
doit encore aujourd'hui aller en se
renforçant
donc juste équilibre entre cet
objectif-là et puis celui de conserver
la liberté matrimoniale pourquoi il faut
conserver la liberté matrimoniale parce
que d'abord parce que c'est une liberté
fondamentale
c'est une liberté essentielle c'est
celle qui consiste tout bonnement à
pouvoir choisir son époux choisir qui il
est mais aussi tout simplement c'est
celle qui consiste en pouvoir décider
qu'on n'a pas envie de se marier voilà
et c'est une liberté essentielle qui a
été reconnu comme tel au même titre que
la liberté d'aller et venir ou que la
liberté d'expression et c'est une
liberté fondamentale parce qu'elle a été
reconnue au niveau international quand
elle est donc elle est consacrée depuis
de longues dates aussi bien dans la
déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme de 1948 que dans la convention
européenne de sauvegarde des droits de
l'homme de 1950 et donc ça soumet le
législateur à une petite difficulté
parce qu'il faut qu'ils puissent lutter
mais que les dispositifs qui met en
place
nay par ne soit pas à ce moment-là
coercitif ou contraignant que finalement
ils mettent à mal la liberté
matrimoniale le législateur il a depuis
une dizaine d'années une quinzaine
d'années maintenant une difficulté ou
une contrainte supplémentaire à
respecter c'est que cette liberté
matrimoniale l on lui a reconnu une
valeur constitutionnelle
en effet le conseil constitutionnel dans
deux décisions la première donc du 13
août 1993
lorsqu'on lui a demandé d'examiner la
réforme de l'époque de en gros la
législation sur l'immigration droit
d'asile etc
il s'est penché sur cette législation et
il a regardé dans ce qui était mis en
place pour contrôler les mariages mixtes
parce que faut appeler un chat un chat
s'était quand même ça est-ce que ce qui
était mis en place était donc justifiée
ou pas et il a regardé à l'aune du fait
qu'il fallait qu'il veille à ce que la
liberté matrimoniale soit conservée
parce qu'il a à ce moment là indiqué que
la liberté matrimoniale c'était une
composante de la liberté individuelle
qui elle même était protégé par la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen et comme la déclaration des
droits de l'homme et du citoyen et dans
le préambule de notre constitution est
la valeur constitutionnelle et de ce
fait la liberté matrimoniale aussi ce
qui veut dire que lorsque les
législateurs intervient il faut qu'il
veille à cela son coin il encourait la
censure du conseil constitutionnel
pour autant ça ne veut pas dire que les
pouvoirs publics doivent rester inactif
au contraire
ils ont mis en place un certain nombre
de dispositifs depuis on va dire
essentiellement il faut le regretter
très tardivement et en gros depuis une
petite dizaine d'années surtout l'or
pour ma part bien sûr je vais insister
essentiellement sur les mariages
célébrés en france puisque vous aurez
quelqu'un de beaucoup plus spécialistes
pour les questions des mariages célébrés
à l'étranger
alors tout d'abord on a essayé de voir
qu'est ce qu'on pouvait faire en amont
c'est à dire qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
avant même que le mariage soit célébré
on a commencé par relever l'âge du
mariage pour les femmes comme vous l'a
rappelé madame jamin on était
extrêmement retard là dessus on avait un
code civil qui prévoyait que l'âge légal
pour se marier pour les femmes était de
15 ans et pour les hommes il était de 18
alors ça comme ça ça peut paraître à
l'évidence choquant il faut voir que ça
venait d'une époque où être enceinte
êtes mariés s'étaient l'opprobre total
et que donc il fallait pouvoir trouver
une solution pour ces jeunes filles le
problème c'est que cette situation elle
a perduré sans qu'on se pose la question
de savoir si on pouvait pas inverser le
principe c'est à dire m la même règle
pour tout le monde
hommes et femmes 18 ans est simplement
prévoir une sorte de protection ou de
prise en compte particulière des
situations des mineurs de 15 ans et plus
qui sera enceinte en prévoyant dans ses
hypothèses là une dispense d'âge alors 7
ce relèvement de l'âge nubile il a fait
suite en fait à l'avis de la commission
nationale consultative des droits de
l'homme qui dès 2005 avait fait de cette
disposition là une préconisation pour
essayer de mieux lutter contre les
mariages forcés et donc là vous avez eu
donc un alignement pour les hommes pour
les fans et en dessous de 18 ans pour
les femmes vous avez une possibilité de
dispense comme la dispense est accordée
par le groupement la république pour
motif grave motif grave c'est ça veut
dire grossesse ça veut dire qu'un
contrôle du procureur ce qui veut aussi
dire que dans les hypothèses où ils
pourraient percevoir qu'il ya une
difficulté particulière à ce moment-là
il interviendrait et éventuellement ne
délivrerait pas de dispense sa
disposition là elle a permis de protéger
en fait de renforcer la protection des
mineurs
le législateur ensuite est intervenu
pour essayer de prendre en compte la
situation de tous les types de mariage
qu'il soit entre mineurs ou entre
majeurs et donc de faire en sorte que
l'on puisse détecter les difficultés en
ayant en posant pour principe que
l'audition préalable au préalable au
mariage des époux devait être
obligatoire en effet l'article 63 du
code civil prévoit que l'officier d'état
civil doit entendre
en fait les futurs époux de façon
séparée j'y reviendrai sauf s'il estime
qu'il n'y a pas de doute sur les
intentions matrimoniale mais la règle
normalement c'est qu'il doit les
entendre
je précise que pour un certain nombre de
raisons le ministère de la justice va
dans dans le courant des mois prochain
sortir une circulaire dans laquelle a
priori cette règle à seraient rappelés
et éventuellement renforcée et l'idée
c'est de faire en sorte que l'ordre
lorsque lors d'un entretien séparé
l'officier d'état civil donc c'est à
dire le maire ses adjoints ou les
personnes qui l'aura délégués dans ces
fonctions là et on entretient avec
chacun des conjoints en posant des
questions très précises pour essayer de
détecter les situations de mariage forcé
je précise que si un interprète est
nécessaire dans ces situations là il est
préconisé de prendre un interprète
évidemment qui ne soit pas lié à la
famille de la même manière si un des
conjoints est mineure il est obligatoire
ou très fortement conseillé de
l'entendre sans son représentant légal
sans quoi évidemment au vu des
situations décrites ça n'aurait aucun
intérêt et l'officier d'état civil s'il
a une suspicion au terme de son de son
audition des époux qu il doit signaler
la situation procureur de la république
alors la difficulté pour lui sans doute
c'est le curseur c'est à dire que vous
faites d une audition avec beaucoup de
questions et un critère seuls et pas
constitutif forcément d'une situation
problématique mais plusieurs critères
aligner doit mener à un signalement et
l'idée là aussi du nissan la justice
s'était donné des instructions aux
officiers d'état civil pour qu'à
l'avenir il signale davantage parce que
la constatation complètent ces cas sans
doute pas cette situation qui remonte si
les situations ne remonte pas au
procureur de la république il n'a
présentement pas la possibilité de
s'opposer au mariage
donc il faut que les offices et est
assise
ils soient sensibilisés et qu'ils
fassent des auditions peut-être plus
approfondie qu'ils y prennent le temps
de le faire et que donc et plus de
choses qui remonte au procureur de la
république
ensuite il faut aussi que les procureurs
puisse diligenter des enquêtes plus
fourni alors je ne vous donnerai pas la
liste précise des critères qui sont
retenus mais globalement l'idée c'est il
ya les critères évidente si vous voyez
un des conjoints les pouces par exemple
qui arrivent avec des bleus bien
évidemment il faut que ça donne un
signalement si vous voyez un les pouces
qui est la future épouse qui arrive avec
une attitude complètement renfermée sur
elle-même complètement mutique l'air
complètement dépressif il faut que ça
alerte
de la même manière si lorsque vous
entendez les époux les versions qu'il
donne des circonstances de leur
rencontre des projets qu'ils envisagent
l'endroit où ils veulent s'établir
est ce qu'elle est ce qu'ils ont un
projet de vie très construite ça doit
signaler sein c'est sans doute un des
critères les plus difficiles parce que à
l'heure où on a un couple sur trois un
mariage sur trois qui aboutit un divorce
c'est vrai qu'on peut considérer que
peut-être dans toutes les unions il ya
peut-être une difficulté à la base de
présent contre mais il faut que cette
critères-là associé à d'autres puissent
permettre éventuellement un signalement
la même manière si vous avez un conjoint
qui arrive menée par sa famille avec la
famille qui attend et qui est comme ça
fait fait en masse et même physiquement
une sorte de pression il faut que ça ça
a l'air de la même manière si elle ne
s'est quasiment jamais présente et elle
porte pour formaliser les démarches
administratives et qu'en fait elles sont
faites par un tiers ou un proche de la
famille il faut aussi que çà çà çà çà
facile sans esprit de l'officier d'état
civil et qui signale la situation une
fois que la situation et signaliez il y
a trois possibilités pour le procureur
il peut soit considéré que les critères
sont pas suffisants les écarter ou ne
rien dire ou donné son accord à la
célébration du mariage ou ne rien dire
ça revient au même à ce moment là le
mariage est célébré
sinon il peut surseoir la célébration du
mariage c'était d'attendre et dire on va
bloquer pendant quinze jours
j'ai quand même décidé on va bloquer
vraiment fait une enquête
l'amp est est transmise au bout d'un
mois d' enquête si ce n'est pas
suffisant je peux avoir encore un mois
d' enquête et au terme de ces deux mois
par contre je dois prendre une décision
ou accor ou opposition au mariage
je précise là aussi pas s'il a fallu
permettre des recours pour préserver la
livre être liberté matrimoniale si les
époux ne sont pas d'accord ils ont la
possibilité de contester le sursis
devant le président du tribunal de
grande instance ou lorsqu il y a
opposition complète au mariage vous
pouvez demander la main levée de cette
position devant le tribunal
mais là du coup il y aura une audience
où chacun pourra s'exprimer un débat
contradictoire et donc par conséquent
une possibilité de détecter la hausse il
ya s'il ya des difficultés lorsque tout
ceci n'a pas pu aboutir vous avez aussi
des bas de recours bien évidemment après
posteriori mais ce qui est sûr c'est que
on se rend compte que c'est sans doute
la marge de manoeuvre la plus grande
qu'on a c'est si on arrive à faire
signaler beaucoup plus de difficultés et
donc c'est dans cet esprit-là que les
pouvoirs publics ont mené depuis un
certain nombre d'années des campagnes de
sensibilisation qu'ils ont mis en ligne
des informations sur le site service
public.fr sursis du plaideur c'est je
crois qu'il ya des informations qui sont
mises en ligne plus spécifique sur les
cadets des mariages à l'étranger vous
avez un certain nombre de communes qui
produisent des plaquettes comme
l'initiative du planning familial
vous avez la mairie de paris qui a fait
une plaquette très bien très bien ciblé
pour expliquer les choses et ensuite
vous avez effectivement une action
possible
a posteriori c'est à dire une
possibilité de demander l'annulation de
votre du mariage cette annulation elle
peut être demandé dans les cinq ans à
compter de la célébration du mariage
et ça c'est une nouveauté qui a été
apportée en 2007 parce que jusque
auparavant considéré que la cohabitation
sans discontinuité pendant six mois
ça couvre est en fait c'est à dire que
si vous aviez une épouse non consentante
entraîné de force dans un mariage qui
finalement sont contentés où il
n'arrivait pas à faire autrement que de
s'en contenter
pendant six mois il y avait une
impossibilité d'agir
de même si la femme s'est retrouvée
enceinte
on s'est rendu compte que du coup on lui
imposait aussi de force non seulement le
mariage mais ensuite une grossesse et
donc depuis 2007 on en est revenu un
délai de cinq ans dans tous les cas à
compter de la célébration du mariage
cette action là elle est ouverte aux
époux bien sûr elle est ouverte aussi au
ministère public ce qui veut dire si la
jeune femme n'arrive pas ou jeune homme
n'arrive pas à réagir parce que c'est
très difficile quand on est dans une
situation d'emprise de se faire à ce
moment-là le pouvoir le ministère public
lui même si on le cas lui est signalée
ça peut être par des tiers il peut agir
en sont tout à fait tout à fait alors
vous avez aussi évidemment ddd règles
précises pour les mariages célébrés à
l'étranger elles vous seront à ce
moment-là retracé par ma collègue du
ministère des affaires étrangères la
transition la transition est toute faite
donc claudine serre vous êtes diplomate
chef du bureau de la protection des
mineurs et de la famille à la direction
des français à l'étranger et vous allez
nous faire la dernière intervention de
cette matinée je sais qu elles ont été
toutes passionnantes et qu'elles auront
toute leur place pour trouver les
meilleures manières de faire les
amendements je dis ça pour christine
jama qui a fait quelques suggestions du
texte qui va arriver dans les jours
prochains j'espère devant nous au sénat
voilà donc madame faire c'est à vous
merci madame après la présidente vous
m'entendez je remercie madame la
présidente je remercie aussi les
sénateurs et des sénatrices qui sont ici
présents dans la salle
les organisateurs de cette conférence
j'essayerai de ne pas vous décevoir car
effectivement les interventions ont été
passionnantes et je ne voudrais faire le
moins officielles possible et le plus
vivant possible si vous le permettez
compte tenu de ce que nous avons entendu
je ne pourrais pas donc de définition
des mariages forcés
vous en avez eu vous le savez mieux que
quiconque en revanche je vous dirais
qu'elles sont nos obligations je
voudrais quand même vous dire la
première chose c'est que le quai d'orsay
est de plus en plus alertés et impliqués
dans la question des mariages forcés
consigne a été
né à tous nos agents consulaires ou
d'être extrêmement attentif sur ces
questions à telle enseigne qu à un
certain nombre d'entre eux réussissent
des opérations en liaison avec le bureau
de la protection des mineurs et de la
famille dont j'assume la responsabilité
et que parfois même ils y arrivent et
que nous n'en sommes pas informés ou non
sans en informer après alors ça n'est
pas pour vous faire présenter une vision
rose ou une vision extrêmement optimiste
pas du tout c'est simplement pour vous
dire que bon jeu il se trouve que
j'occupe ses fonctions depuis près de
trois ans et que en trois ans nous avons
vu multiplier les opérations et les
réussites je dirais par trois ou quatre
et je voudrais saluer madame la
présidente si vous le permettez d'abord
votre action quand vous étiez ministre
je m'en souviens très bien
à titre personnel et d'autre part le
salut et des associations tirons ici
présentés qui sont intervenus avec
lesquels je dois vous dire que nous
travaillons en étroite que le quai
d'orsay et travaille en étroite
collaboration
alors la première chose que nous devons
faire parce que nous sommes quand même
un organisme public c'est la
vérification
c'est notre première difficulté notre
première opération c'est que lorsque
nous sommes informés d'une situation
nous devons faire la distinction entre
un projet sur des véritables intentions
de mariage ou un projet de cas réels de
mariage forcé il est il est nécessaire
c'est nécessaire pour nous en effet nous
avons déjà eu à connaître c'est un
faible pourcentage mais c'est un
pourcentage qui existe nous avons déjà
eu à connaître de fausses alertes
deux jeunes femmes qui prétendait à
l'étranger avoir perdu leurs papiers
alors qu'en réalité sur ordre de leur
famille très souvent elle avait dû les
vendre
c'est rare ça n'est pas la majorité
comme je vous le dis c'est une minorité
mais c'est une minorité qui existe et en
tant que ministère public nous sommes
obligés de vérifier que les papiers
n'ont pas été vendus ensuite dès lors
que la vérité des faits est établi nous
donnons aux femmes de nationalité
française ou bi national car en réalité
nous nous retrouvons très souvent avec
des capes ou remises affaires étrangères
avec des cas de femmes binationale pour
lesquels dans le pays où elle se trouve
elles sont considérées comme de la
nationalité du terrible sur le
territoire sur lequel elle se trouve
alors que pour nous elles sont
considérées comme des citoyennes
françaises donc c'est nous leur donnons
immédiatement dès que nous en sommes
informés assistance de la part de notre
réseau diplomatique et consulaire
ça veut dire conseil comme vous le savez
mais aussi hébergement sécurisé vous ne
peux je ne peux pas vous donner de
chiffres pour des raisons de discrétion
et vite évidente mais nous avons
régulièrement dans nos consulats et même
dans nos ambassades
nous avons régulièrement dans nos
consulats et même temps nos ambassades
des jeunes femmes qui ont failli être
victimes de mariages forcés et avant que
nous puissions les rapatrier en france
car on ne les sors pas de manière
forcément évidente tout de suite du
territoire dans lequel elle se trouve
eh bien ces jeunes femmes vivent au
consulat ou à l'ambassade et il y as
parfois il ya parfois je dois le dire
sur le plan personnel il y a parfois des
solidarités des chaînes de solidarité
qui dépasse le ministère la fonction
publique qui se crée entre les membres
de l'ambassade et du consulat qui se
relaient chaque soir et chaque jour pour
que la jeune femme
des jeunes femmes ne soient pas seules
pour qu'elles un environnement pour
qu'elle se sente entouré donc je cède
pour vous dire que véritablement cette
question à la fois est devenu beaucoup
plus officiel et en même temps a pris un
caractère humain une dimension humaine
plus large alors ensuite lorsqu'il y à
audition nous agents consulaires font de
plus en plus comme vous le savez
auditions des époux lors de la
publication des bans ou lors de la
demande de transcription de l'acte de
mariage à l'étranger et l'agent
consulaire peut être amener à surseoir à
la transcription de l'acte est assez y
revient le service central civile à
nantes le procureur de la république en
vue de statuer sur la validité de
l'union et cela nous permet donc
effectivement d'avoir fait arrêter un
certain nombre de deux
de mariage qu'ils allaient être des
mariages forcés et qui se traduit par
comme l'a souligné notre ma collègue du
ministère de justice par une
augmentation du nombre de saisines du
parquet au titre de l'article 170 1 du
code civil
mais bien sûr dans le cas de double
nationalité comme je voulais expliquer
l'exercice de la protection consulaire
peut être plus délicat et l'a
véritablement je dois dire que notre
réseau consulaire et diplomatique
les relations personnelles qu'il
entretient aussi avec les autorités sur
place sont extrêmement importantes
nous avons vu un cas par exemple que
nous n'aurions pas soupçonné puis nous
avons pu régler de deux cas de risque de
mariages forcés pour des jeunes femmes
franco pakistanaise où toute la famille
était retourné au pakistan dans une
ville éloignée du pakistan et vous vous
imaginez bien qu'avec le poids familial
le poids aussi de la tribu sur place
nous pensions enfin nous avions peur
disons nous avions peur de ne pas
pouvoir résoudre cette question et bien
nous sommes tombés sur une coopération
avec les autorités le maire de l'avis
des autorités locales qui a été plus
importante que nous ne pouvions même
respirer et ces jeunes filles sont
rapatriés elles sont maintenant dans un
autre lieu dans une autre ville en
france elles ont repris leurs études de
lycée alors il ya également nous pouvons
dans le cas d'un mariage forcé décidé de
non délivrance d'un visa du conjoint il
est étranger voire de non délivrance ou
prorogation de titre de séjour
le cas échéant nous travaillons
également en liaison en étroite liaison
avec les services sociaux français les
établissements scolaires et bien entendu
avec tous les services de nombreux
contacts avec la défenseure des enfants
lorsque la personne concernée est une
mineure et la défenseure des enfants
nous facilitent facilite les démarches
administratives et judiciaires de gens
de protection judiciaire et sociale de
ces jeunes français
enfin nous intéresse nous faisons il ya
également des interventions auprès des
procureurs des juges pour enfants et du
parquet de nantes
mais je voudrais quand même rendre un
hommage tout particulier
la vice présidente madame cameraman a dû
partir mais je voudrais rendre
tout particulier au fait que d'abord
nous avons 250 postes diplomatiques et
consulaires qui sont très sensibilisés
sur ces questions qui agissent de plus
en plus là-dessus mais je voudrais
également dit on va parler de nos
consuls qui sont dits un horaire qui se
trouvent parfois dans des villages ou
dans des petites villes et qui
interviennent très de manière très
active et enfin je voudrais rendre
hommage aux représentants de l'assemblée
des français à l'étranger
les représentants des assemblées des
français de l'étranger nous alertent de
plus en plus au quai d'orsay où dans nos
ambassades pour justement sur ces sur
ces questions et donc cela nous est très
précieux car cela nous fait un certain
nombre de réseaux parallèles et plus
nous avons de réseaux parallèles plus à
titre officiel nous pouvons sauver des
jeunes filles ou parfois des jeunes
hommes en difficulté
alors je vais vous proposer quelques
exemples rapidement si madame la
présidente vous laisser encore cinq
petites minutes
quelques exemples je voudrais vous
donner un exemple sur l'algérie au mois
de juin 2009
donc le bureau de la protection des
mineurs et des familles a été saisi par
l'association femmes informations
juridiques internationales de la
situation d'une mineure qui avait subi
en 2005 c'est à dire voici cinq ans des
coups et blessures de la part de son
frère
elle était alors âgée de 14 ans et elle
avait été envoyé en algérie auprès de
son père avec la complicité de son frère
violent nous sommes en 2005 en juin 2009
notre consul à oran a été sollicité par
cette association qui souhaitaient avoir
un contact avec la jeune fille mais elle
ne savait pas où elle se trouvait en
algérie
nous avons mobilisé tous nos services et
tous nos consulats en algérie il nous a
fallu des mois de recherches et après
ces mois de recherches nous avons réussi
à localiser la jeune fille il faut vous
dire que parfois nous n'y parvenons pas
en dépit de toutes les recherches que
nous faisons donc ça n'est pas évident
un retournement de situation a eu lieu
en janvier de cette année lorsque la
jeune fille qui était devenu majeur
s'est enfui de l'endroit où elle où elle
avait été localisée et où nous l'avions
localiser je ne vous dirai pas comment
elle s'est en fait s est enfui elle
s'est présentée au consulat de france à
oran
elle a sollicité notre aide et notre
retour et depuis janvier nous assurons
c'est à dire notre ambassade assurent la
sécurité de cette ressortie de notre
ressortissant tel à une protection
renforcée et nous travaillons au
rapatriement de cette jeune fille en
france
bien évidemment nous veillons en même
temps à ce que cette jeune femme
lorsqu'elle sera en france sera
accueilli dans un centre et non à
l'endroit où réside son frère
enfin nous avons eu un problème deuxième
exemple nous avons eu une jeune mineure
en 2009 qui a été obligé d'être mariée
avec un cousin et qui s'est présenté au
consulat de france à abidjan
et là pendant en moins de deux mois deux
mois peut vous paraître long mais pour
nous nous devons quand même
nous avons affaire aussi aux autorités
locales en moins de 9 ans de 2 mois nous
avons réussi à assurer son rapatriement
elle est maintenant protégé également et
bénéficie également d'une ordonnance de
placement provisoire en france nous
avons eu également une affaire en eau
mali et puis je voudrais terminer parce
que je ne veux pas faire long j'en ai un
certain non mais je voudrais madame la
présidente
si vous le permettez par les deux cas de
la turquie parce que la turquie nous
commençons à voir de plus en plus de cas
de mariage forcé en turquie et là ça se
passe de manière légèrement différente
des autres c'est à dire en mars 2009
notre ambassade notre consulat dans une
des villes de turquie est alerté sur le
fait qu'une jeune majeur parce que c'est
nous et nous traitons les mineurs mais
ne traitant s'il est majeur
une jeune mannequin majeurs qui étaient
très vulnérables sur le plan
psychologique apparaissent est prête à
épouser une personne qu'elle n'avait vu
qu'elle connaissait à peine qu'elle
n'avait vu qu'une fois en résine en
turquie c'était une jeune matcher
fragile psychologiquement franco
française et qui ne savaient même pas
communiquer avec lui puisqu'il ne
parlait pas une seule langue en commun
est en réalité donc elle a été déplacée
en turquie elle s'est retrouvée au
milieu une famille turque qui avait
l'air extrêmement bien organisée et qui
avaient été mises en contact par une
pièce de personnes il s'avère en réalité
que nous assistons de plus en plus alors
je ne veux pas vous donner des chiffres
importants mais je veux dire par là que
nous
alertons là dessus madame la présidente
sur le fait qu'il y a de plus en plus de
trafic de mariages forcés sur des jeunes
femmes des jeunes majeurs vulnérables
psychologiquement en france et que
internet joue un rôle également non
négligeable sur lequel je souhaite me
direz votre attention car nous avons de
plus en plus de cas nous avons eu le cas
par exemple il y a deux mois d'une grand
mère nous avons je dois vous dire je le
dis mesdames et messieurs pour vous qui
avez des connaissances et des grands
mères et des grands pères
n'hésitez pas à leur parler parce que de
plus en plus ce sont les grands parents
qui nous alerte puisque les parents sont
souvent complices eh bien il peut y
avoir des prend par an qui nous alerte
et nous avons ainsi eu une grand mère et
un grand-père qui nous ont alerté il ya
trois mois sur une jeune fille qui sur
internet était entré en relation avec un
jeune homme d'un pays du maghreb qui
l'avait courtisé qui en réalité
souhaitait simplement des papiers
français
nous avons eu beaucoup de mal car la
jeune fille était complètement sous
influences qu'on appelle sous influence
et il nous a fallu toute la force des
pouvoirs publics pour pouvoir sauver
cette jeune fille à la demande de ses
grands parents et même de son père alors
je pourrais continuer longtemps mais
leur à tourner je ne veux donc pas faire
plus long je voudrais vous dire
véritablement rendre hommage à tous les
services parallèles comme je dis
consulaires et consuls honoraires
assemblée des français de l'étranger et
vous dire que en tout cas des à chaque
fois que le ministère des affaires
étrangères et européennes est saisie
d'un dossier concernant un projet de
mariage forcé nous essayons toujours de
localiser la personne
nous incitons les jeunes qui sont les
amis à avoir des photocopies des pièces
d'identité à nous appeler parce que par
téléphone portable parfois nous arrivons
à les joindre et en tout cas nous tenons
à vous dire que nous avons à notre
modeste nous niveau réussi à venir en
aide et à faire échec à un certain
nombre d'unions
nous pouvons considérer que c'est
environ 30 par an pour ce qui concerne
le quai d'orsay depuis paris mais qu'il
y ait un certain nombre de mises en
échec dont nous n'avons pas les chiffres
car nos consulats quand ils ont fait le
travail estiment qu'ils ont fait le
travail
je vous remercie merci beaucoup pour ce
ces deux témoignages mais merci beaucoup
pour ces témoignages du moment et ce
rôle de nos agents alerté par fois par
nos collègues sénateurs des français à
l'étranger avec lequel le travail est
constant également donc c'est très
précieux réconfortant de savoir qu'il ya
des recours qu'il y a des possibilités
et que tout cela reste dans le droit
puisque le code du mariage c'est vrai il
ya la liberté mais il ya aussi des
démarches et je pense que c'est problème
là sont extrêmement importants sont pas
toujours sans doute les plus fascinants
les plus passionnants pour un débat mais
nous sommes dans ce cadre et nous sommes
respectueux de ce cadre légal quel
régime du mariage en france avec sa
liberté ses contraintes et donc je veux
remercier nos deux dernières
intervenantes et et les trois dernières
dont j'ai été privé d'une partie des
interventions
je le regrette infiniment mais
connaissant catherine mort bois son
engagement connaissant l'engagement du
planning familial des plannings
familiaux qui sont parfois aussi fait
deux militantes qui connaissent elles
mêmes ces situations de mariage forcé ou
de dureté à leur égard eh bien je sais
combien ce travail est précieux et
madame jamais je pense que nous aurons à
faire ensemble pour faire avancer très
précisément la législation quand elle
devra et le contrôle également parce que
le rôle des parlementaires c'est aussi
contrôler et nous le savons et nous
devons l'exercer en permanence je vais
peut-être prendre une ou deux questions
il y à des questions précises je crois
qu'il serait bien que nous allions
déjeuner vers 13h pour redémarrer à
l'heure alors les questions j'ai vu des
mains au fond là-bas la dernière
personne au fond là-bas une deux ou
trois débrouillez vous c'est vrai que
j'avais grande et a parlé tout à l'heure
et excusez moi est-ce que vous
m'accordez de commencer madame bonjour
merci je remercie surtout le sénat de
nous avoir invités sedin us c'est une
source d'instruction au moins pour le
moins d'être ici donc c'est merci
beaucoup au palais du sénat
j'ai une petite attention pour la
conseillère municipale je n'ai pas
retenu son nom car je pense
effectivement au travail qui est
réservée aux mères au conseiller aux
adjoints
quand ils sont devant les mariages et
déjà entendu des narrations je me suis
dit qu'est ce que j'aurais fait à leur
place
voilà bien si je ne fais pas partie d'un
conseil municipal je ne suis pas
présentée je suis simplement membres de
l'association des femmes françaises
diplômés d'université voilà c'est dans
ce cadre que je suis ici par internet et
j'ai répondu voilà alors ce qui va
alerter
dans le contexte les les mariages forcés
il m'est venue du des suivantes c'est de
retourner un petit peu l'expression en
ce sens la force du mariage dans la
société
dans les sociétés l'institution du
mariage dans la société en général à
toutes les surfaces de la planète
la puissance du mariage d'où vient-elle
récemment nous avons eu une jeune
thésarde qui nous a parlé de la le
mariage dans la noblesse tibétaine elle
y est allée on lui a donné pour ça l'a
aidé dans la noblesse tibétaine est bien
un homme une femme a le droit d'avoir un
nombre illimité dépouille ou des pouces
alors nous sommes regardés nous des plus
anciennes je n'étais pas au courant je
parle dit
et bien c'est comme ça le père l'enfant
qui naît c'est l'aîné le père le plus
vieux qui est le père voilà bon enfin
lâché m'arrêter là donc la surface de la
planète du tibet moi j'ai passé aux
eskimos scheer descendu au brésil dans
ma tête et je me suis dit mais enfin et
voilà aujourd'hui c'est ça qu'elle est
pourquoi cette force du mariage pourquoi
cette puissance cette référence sociale
quel mariage à la surface de la planète
voilà
et je suis contente de voir à la
deuxième table ronde deux personnes
service juridique car derrière le
mariage il y à cette question pourquoi
été si puissant et derrière le mariage
il est vrai qu'une législation
il ya une foule de choses pourquoi
mène-t-il de monde et quelle est la
législation derrière ça nous ne
l'abordons pas sauf pour quand on a dit
on peut avoir la nationalité a réagi etc
voilà mais même pour les européennes il
ya la notion juridique
la notion du contrat de mariage et à ce
moment là qu'elle quelle est la
législation d'ailleurs ça peu de gens y
pensent les maires madame blanc a dit
quelque chose de très bien c'est une
quelque chose qui va se faire je crois
elle a dit que c'était en vue c'est là
la discussion
convoqué un peu les deux fiancés enfin
un futur époux pour leur demander pour
va vraiment où va ce mariage et quelles
sont les raisons de ce mariage mais sur
le plan juridique on n'expose jamais les
avantages car il doit y en avoir puisque
le mariage est tellement de succès mais
les risques aussi ça jamais jamais la
mairie ou un service juridique ne
convoque les jeunes futurs époux pour
leur dire attention bien pour ça mais
attention les pma da voilà merci
beaucoup mais si nous voulons prendre
quelques questions parce que là je vais
me faire écharper au déjeuner et charbon
jours les jeunes et voilà madame bonjour
je me présente je vais vous faire court
on pourra les premières craintes
d'accord linda linda ramoul du réseau
osez le féminisme qui est
un réseau d'information et de
sensibilisation à la question des droits
des femmes est pas et pas une
association qui accompagne qui pour 20
points sedan je pense
les victimes de ce genre de violence moi
j'avais j'ai deux questions la première
c'est comment on peut renforcer
l'accompagnement de ces jeunes majeurs
qui sont en difficulté et qui n'ont pas
forcément eu de suivi à quand elle était
mineure et aujourd'hui quand elles sont
jeunes majeurs comment on peut les
accompagner parce que financier d'un
point de vue de l'autonomie en général
elles sont assez très démunis
du coup je vais savoir comment on
pouvait les accompagner et j'avais une
autre question concernant les les les
mariages à l'étranger
comment être on peut collaborer donc les
services qu'on sait pas comment on
collabore avec des autorités locales
parce que je pense que dans certains
pays c'est assez difficile d'accepter
que des personnels d'expliquer comment
on doit gérer les relations dans un
couvent et cetera au familial et ça
voilà merci allait rapidement une
réponse à cette question parce que la
première intervention paraît si vous me
paraissez des informations
complémentaires
1 la question la madame rama non mais la
réponse elle est purement financière il
faut des moyens supplémentaires pour
accompagner les femmes notamment les
conseils généraux les jeunes majeurs si
les conseils généraux ils ont moins de
moyens donc on se s'autorise - à
protéger quand on a moins de moyens et
appréhender cherchons des assauts ce
qu'on a encore moins d'excusés mois dure
cette réponse là mais ensuite pour le
moins clair le travail qui peut être
fait avec avec les pays d'origine enfin
les autorités sur place c'est un travail
de fourmi là c'est là c'est pareil il
faut encore plus de moyens il faut quand
même aussi s'appuyer sur la législation
existante moi je suis intervenu à rabat
dans un colloque au départ j'avais fait
d'un terreau vendre un tel texte un peu
alambiqué où je parlais de consentement
et m'ont dit mais non vous nous parler
du match force et c'est eux qui m'ont
demandé d'utiliser ce terme parce que là
bas ils ont une législation contre
mariage forcé sauf que et social et l
epa a donc forcément donc là parce qu'il
ya des mariages coutumiers qui seront
célébrés à la place des mariages
religieux voilà c'est tout
c'est la fin de cette table ronde
consacrée à la prévention des mariages
forcés si vous souhaitez la revoir notre
site internet publicsenat.fr
à suivre le journal de 18 heures
présenté par michel grossiord bonne
soirée à tous sur public sénat